so very happy to be here and I'm
georgius Georges malikas currently I'm a
lead data scientist and I'm working at
sex for search trying to improve the
performance of the sales engine there in
general I'm very passionate about
information retrieval natural language
processing and machine learning I really
enjoy projects that are intersection are
in the section of these fields currently
I'm trying to balance between Career
family I have tuitions and sports I live
in Grenoble France and it's just below
the Alps now it starts snowing and I'm
very excited about this too I'm trying
to learn ski I'm playing some tennis I
love cycling I also love wine and cheese
and if you want to reach out you can
reach out in Twitter you can reach out
in LinkedIn or even GitHub and as a
matter of fact I would presenting about
an open source GitHub project I've been
working on last in the last few months
right now
so what's the talk what's the story
behind this talk in particular well I
wanted to try send this Transformers
it's like bird style models Transformers
models that have been beating the state
of the art in several tasks during the
last few years since this Transformers
is a python package that lets you use
such models but how do we put such a
model in production well it's not that
easy and the most of these models they
work on top of pythons usually in
production setting at least in our case
we want to search as a model with types
of a lot so first of something we want
to have a single graph so that you have
a query you hit the graph with a query
and you get predictions well it's not
really how these models work you have a
tokenizer and then you query the model
so this along with other challenges in
the process inspired me to write this
open source framework that's called
tensorflow exponent exported and it's
currently available at GitHub I will be
setting the URL shortly after
so the outline of my talk now I hope I
have convinced you that there is
something new for you to attend it so
I'll start explaining a bit more the
problem and then I will Deep dive in the
sentence Transformer packets
architecture hopefully a solution will
arise and this will bring us naturally
to the tensorflow exporter packets that
I've been working on so let's start with
the program statement
this is what you would do in a python
notebook environment if you wanted to
use the census Transformers Library you
would first pip install it and then you
will import the send as a former class
you would Define a model name send this
Transformers all mini LM L6 V2 in this
case you will initialize the class and
well you can get embeddings just by
calling and code you can keep that you
can hidden code with a single string I
data is awesome like I'm doing here or
even with a bus of strings and you would
get embeddings these embeddings at this
case is like vectors of floats of
dimensional 368 for this particular
model and you can use them in a
downstream in a dancing task you can do
information retrieval you can do
classification natural language
inference there are several tasks where
these models perform quite well once you
have the embeddings of course so you
have the model you get a string you get
embeddings and you continue on on your
pipeline
but what exactly is happening behind
this the scenes of these uh model Dot
and code method where a lot of things
are happening in
but this is a screenshot taken from the
having phase Hub model cart of this
particular model we see that there is a
tokenizer that is initialized there is a
model that is initialized and then we
start the process by querying using the
tokenizer the tokenizer itself does
several things it not only does it give
us the tokens but it also does padding
it also does Plantation so a lot of
goodies packed in there once the input
is tokenized again this can be either a
single string or a bus and then you hear
the model
that is not it then you need to know a
few things about the model and here in
this case the model does mean pulling on
on top of the model outputs and then
there is also a normalization step this
is not the case for every model inside
this Transformers different settings
Transformer models require different
steps after this model output steps so
we need a way that against gay
and all these right now are happening
mostly with Python's code and pythons
perhaps see this F here with the pythons
uh
token weights for the models so there is
a discrepance between pythons and
tensorflow
now the question that natural realizes
and what I'm trying to answer in this
presentation is that Kenwood bring some
of these goodies in the tensorflow world
in particular can we have a single graph
that does all of the steps that the
previous slide sold tokenization query
the model and perhaps post-processing of
the model predictions if we had a single
graph that can do this it would be
easier to maintain and perhaps a lot
easier to put such a single artifacts in
production instead of having several
things several moving Pieces Just One
graph
if we could do it and we had if we had a
single graph then it would be language
dependent then we're not really tied in
Python anymore
Java and jvm in particular can read
tensorflow models and it's easier if you
have let's say monolithic that is
written in one of these
jvm languages to integrate with it so
it's it's a nice it's a nice thing we
can do it and there's a lot of infra for
serving tensorflow now of course
discussion cup but things are moving
slower in the industry so perhaps one
can use this infra to serve a tensorflow
Model A model that is written in pythons
like most of the semester models it's
not a trivial problem like trying myself
to find the solution I found several
GitHub issues that motivate me further
to dive and understand what is happening
behind the scenes and it's also a fun
exercise I like I really enjoy sales
Transformers and hiding face
Transformers in particular they work
very well
tied together and they Define exercise
like to dig in and try to understand how
this Frame Works what's the architecture
how do they work and how you can build
on top of that
and that was the motivation the problem
we have torch model which is like a
sequence of a tokenizer a model and
perhaps other layers
and we want to be able to have a single
tensorflow graph how can we come up with
a solution well before coming up with a
solution we need really to understand a
bit more about the magic so what is
happening when one initializes sentence
Transformer class with a model name
uh we'll send some Transformers tries to
see if this is a local path or it's just
a model a model named and the model
lives in having phase Hub let's take for
instance the case where it lives in hug
and face Hub then it automatically tries
to bring this model on your local
environment and this model is cast on a
particular path that you can of course
change if you want to but by default it
is cast on the torch cast path on your
local machine and it's not only a single
file that is brought in your local
machine but it's several files like
those that you see in the left part of
my of my of my slide in this case now as
you can see these are a mix of Json
files Json attempts to configuration
probably you've done it have to and
there is also binary files binary files
title Python's model bin these are model
ways there are also text files
vocabulary vocab vocabulary.text so this
for those of you that have worked on it
means like mostly tokenizer
configuration so that we can to organize
the input now if we're looking for a
single source of Truth to make sense out
of this there is one particular file
which is called modules dot Json and its
contents are shown on the right part of
my slide and it's a list of addiction
it's a list of dictionaries in
particular now modulus json.json says
describes the exact architecture of each
of the models and here we're looking at
the architecture not of all many model
but of this model that's called the
distributes birth multilingual cased V1
and what we see is that this model is
like essentially three things first of
all there is a Transformer part and this
is the first part then there is a second
part which is called pulling and then
the third part because it's called delis
what it really means is that you get the
query you first pass it by a Transformer
you do pulling on top of the Transformer
outputs and then there is another dense
layer that further transforms the
pulling outputs
each one of these three model has a
dictionary with like 40 Value pairs what
we care about here is okay the order the
path
so here you see the path of the polling
is one pulling and the type the type is
used by the library by the library
internally so that it initializes a
Transformer Class Type given the
information that lives in this path and
the information here refers to config or
cap and other files
when we have more
elements in this sequence like pulling
and dense we can see that we have these
colors directories and essentially you
can see here one pulling is a directory
in this path
to dance is another directory on this
path and essentially each of these
directories contains can contain
configuration file like the case with
pull it we only have a config.json file
that describes how the pulling will be
done and then for the dance model we
have a config file and weights for a
dense model the config contains
the number the structure of the dense
layer input neurons output neurons and
then the activation function also and
the binary file here contains the
weights of the dense model
in dots
format
as a summary here we discussed that
there is a modules Json file that
describes the architecture of the model
and then its module in this module Json
file can have one or more directories so
One Directory associated with it and its
director can contain one or more files
that describes the users of these uh
module and these are used internally by
some Transformers in order to initialize
a particular class that is used as a
part of a sequential model to get
predictions out of it now this at this
point perhaps has already given you some
ideas on how One Can Do I can get this
architecture get this Transformer model
and translate it in in a tensorflow
uh in the desert flow graph in the Tesla
World essentially the steps so in the
slide but first we need to read on the
stand and pass these modules Json file
depending on the contents of this
monetization file we need to implement
each of these modules in a way that
scales and extends with tensorflow code
and then once we have all these modules
well defined and sequential data's model
perhaps that will be a leading on the
tensorflow award so this brings
everything together
and without further delays let me start
discussing a bit how I decided to
implement this as part of the types of
flow TF exported packets
well there's no surprise after deep
diving into the sentence architecture
and the centers Transformers package
architecture I decided to implement
exactly the steps that we saw in the
previous slide in a way that scales and
in a way that could be used to convert
several models into tensorflow into
tensorflow graph
now doing this is not exactly trivial
like uh when you discuss the differences
between tensorflow and pythons there are
a lot of moving pieces and people tend
to implement things in their own special
way so there were at least two important
resources that came to help creating
this task one was tensorflow test text
tensorflow text is the packets that
delay that it surrounds the tensorflow
world and it's in this ecosystem and it
provides a lot of utilities that can be
used for text post processing and
pre-processing tasks so it makes it
quite easy to work on tensors on Metal
Flow framework and then of course there
is adding phase Transformers which is
one of the packages that have really
democratized Transformers and birth in
the python world and this framework is
written in a way that but it can allow
them to distant artifacts both from
types of flow and from pythons and
oftentimes it makes it very easy to read
the model and save it in a different
the different framework
one of the most important and
challenging tasks was how to convert the
tokenizer and transform a model in a
single graph
this was not trivial because the
tokenizer does a lot of things
essentially and we have to maintain
alignment between
uh the sender Transformer dot tokenize
method implementation with what we would
write in the types of flow text world so
what is essentially tokenizer a
tokenizer is a code that gets a string
it's tokenized uh tokenizes it based on
the particular lookup table look at the
local table is a set of vocabulary
tokens these are some work tokens and
it's used to well split the text in the
tokens so that the model can transform
them into embeddings this can be
implemented using tensorflow text Dot
vert tokenizer method class it already
exists it just needs correct correct
initializations from information that
already lives in this group of Json
configuration files that I showed you
that are cast by send this Transformer
so once you have text input or a batch
of text you just hit the tokenizer the
tokenizer is implemented with birth
tokenizer and it gives you the tokens
essentially
this time so this word style models they
really need text that it's up to a
maximum length so there is a round robin
trimmer that can be used afterwards to
ensure a maximum length so let's say 512
tokens
and now the output of the this part is a
sequence potentially essentially
sequence of tokens that all have a
maximum length
and we need to start and then the token
these are particular tokens that are
used by these Transformer models it's
easy to add them with standard
tensorflow tension operations so I'm not
describing the implementation right here
and then we need to do padding padding
Essentials that every
tensor in the butts
has the same dimensions if some of them
are shorter then we bought them and this
is what public does there is a pad model
inputs implementation within the
tensorflow text packets and this can be
used and at this point we have exactly
the tokenization output that send this
transformer.inize
generates and at this point we can hit a
tensorflow auto model
it's called Auto model here because well
it can read
a hiding phase Transformer models both
from PI parts or
tensorflow
model weights so it automatically
decides and it also automatically
um
decides the architecture of the model
now you hit the model with this output
of the public layer and then at that
point you get the model output uh
and bearings
of course in the previous slide I
described that the story does not finish
there there is also pulling there is
also it can be there can be
normalization there can be dense layer
on top of these outputs but these are
probably simpler to implement uh using
tensorflow
and trying to get uh
the third models to work with tensorflow
I've been doing this in the package but
I didn't want to save I wanted to save
time and not go through
more details on that so this as a result
we have tensorflow exporter which is
like a package that currently lives in
GitHub you can use it as shown in the
Excel on my screen python convert to a
single graph you provide a modern name
it expects the settings Transformer
model and it outputs on the directory of
your choice at tensorflow model it
automatically saves the assets carries
with the data and the same model
protobuf and variables so everything
that you need in order to load the model
from transfer flow and query
the process has been like we need to
maintain some sanity so part of the
process was answering the question how
can we be sure that everything is
aligned so what uh essentially this is
the testing strategy that tensorflow
exporter and myself have been using
throughout the process we first start
with a model sentence Transformer models
we have test queries we use the model
and we get the predictions then
everything is typed in a Keras model
using the process that I described in
the previous slide you have the Keras
processor in memory and you can query
the model and get the predictions of
course you use the same test queries so
these predictions needs to match with
the semesters for the standard
Transformer model predictions and then
there is a last step model persistence
where you get us dot save the model and
then you texture flow.load the model
essentially at that point you had a
graph and you have a servic signature
and you can hit this graph with test
queries and again get tensors get the
output of the model what we really want
is for all these outputs too much and
this is like sanity taking and testing
as it is done in the tensorflow exporter
modeling
I'd like to thank you this model
currently lives in GitHub issues and
suggestions and PLS are very welcome and
feel free to reach out to me either at
Twitter or at LinkedIn or at GitHub in
every device I will be around in the
controls I'm attending this I will be
also on this course thank you thank you
very much